bonjour
quand vous parlez de votre éducation que
vous avez reçu qui était très
patriotique on croyait en la France ça
peut expliquer pourquoi alors vous vous
êtes engagé dans la Résistance alors moi
je suis rentré dans la résistance pour
différentes raisons la première et la
plus rapide ça a été l'invasion du pays
hein être occupé
euh c'était insupportable
bon la deuxème raison
euh ça a été le nazisme parce que mon
père était parlait l'allemand qu'il
avait appris chez les jésuites
et il était il travaillait au câble de
Lyon et comme ingénieur et il allait
pour les foires en Allemagne à lebzig à
Munich depuis des années il a vu la
montée du nazisme il en a été
horrifié euh donc il quand il revenait
d'une d'un voyage en Allemagne il nous
expliquait ce qui se passait qu'on
brûlait les livres pour lui c'était
l'horreur
euh il il nous disait euh que c'était
insupportable ce régime et cetera donc
on on était antinazi avant même que les
nazis viennent chez nous moi je me
rappelle ma mère adorait inviter les les
ingénieurs les enfin ou ses amis et je
me rappelle de je me souviens bien d'un
iné euh où un ingénieur a dit regardez
la jeunesse allemande comme elle est
propre comme elle est courageuse comme
elle est saine euh et mon père lui a dit
mais euh il y a des soubassements
idéologiques insupportables ils se sont
disputés ça a failli ma mère a failli
voir son dîner tourner au vinaigre mais
à 16 ans est-ce que vous pensez pas
aussi que c'était le goût de l'interdit
de d'avoir envie de faire quelque chose
mais c'était un jeu en même temps alors
alors ce que vous dites n'est pas
complètement vrai mais é vrai en grande
partie alors
euh ça nous donnait l'occasion de faire
quelque chose moi j'ai pas été très
heureuse dans l'enseignement secondaire
j'avais envie de rire et de faire rire à
les autres j'avais envie puis dit donc
vous vous rendez pas compte comment on
était vissé nous hein le prof il était
derrière le bureau c'est lui qui avait
raison en permanence et on avait même
pas le droit de lever le doigt pour
l'interrompre euh on était puni pour un
rien c'était pas très très rigolo alors
moi je me disais il doit y avoir moyen
d'enseigner en rendant les élèves
heureux en partageant ce qu'on aime
c'est pour ça que je suis devenu
professeur de lettre après pour pas
faire comme mê et euh c'est vrai que
j'avais un tempérament un peu révolté je
me suis révolté chez moi parce que
j'avais six frères euh et deux sœurs et
que nous faisions les filles faisaient
le travail en particulier ma sœur qui
avait desin de moins que moi et moi on
faisait les lits de mes frères avant de
partir en classe et je trouvais ça
insupportable mais ma mère en bonne
épouse de cette époque considérait que
les femmes devaient tenir la maison et
nous on faisait les mêmes études que nos
frères ce qui était une chance pour nous
d'ailleurs parce que beaucoup de filles
ne faisaient pas d'études euh mais on
rait alors mes frères il devaient porter
la poubelle au fond du au bout du jardin
jusque dans la rue mais comme ils
étaient 6 ils travaillaient un jour par
semaine à porter la poubelle nous étent
tous les matins
elle me rappelle des souvenirs déjà
cette rue c'est tout près de l'endroit
où où j'habitais il y avait des voisins
qui s'appelent les glopes et ils avaient
un mur mitoyen leur jardin avait un mur
mitoyen avec notre jardin et vers 42
quand quand les choses ont commencé à
devenir difficiles pour nous après
l'occupation de la zone libre ses
voisins
avaient proposé à
maman de se préparer
à enfin de préparer ses enfants à
franchir le mur les trois aînés au moins
au cas où les Allemands viendrai nous
chercher et il y avait ils avaient mis
une échelle de leur côté de façon à ce
que nous puissions passer chez eux et il
se ils avaient dit qu'il nous cacheraiit
ou bien que il nous aideraiit à fuir et
là aussi
c'était des Français tout ce qu'il y a
de de
classique ni pétiniste ni
antipétiniste des gens tranquilles
euh je viens de dire le non et voilà que
je le lis sur la boîte
euh 60 presque 70 ans après c'était la
famille glope et leur maison moi je la
reconnais et je vois ce mur qui était le
mur mitoyen avec le jardin de mes
parents
ah je reconnais bien la maison là c'est
c'est émouvant mais c'est sympathique de
repenser à ces gens qui qui ont su
rester fraternels dans des moments où
c'était pas sans danger pour eux non
plus voilà c'est revenir ici c émouvant
pour moi parce
que notre villa qui était qui avait un
grand jardin a été ma mère a déménagé en
89 et notre villa a été détruite pour
faire un immeuble
et j'ai été très peiné de voir le jardin
disparaître avec tous ces beaux arbres
des pains des tyules des CIA et cetera
parce que nous avons été très heureux
quand nous étions enfants mes parents
s'entendaient bien moi j'étais très
proche de mon père j'étais la fille aîné
et il parlait beaucoup avec nous les
repas ont toujours été un moment
d'échange mon frère aîné aimait un peu
le taquiné sur des sujets politiques
religieux et mon père répondait et
on il s'adressait moi à l'époque quand
j'avais 14 15 ans il s'adressait à moi
d'une manière tout tout à fait
respectueuse à condition que je réponde
de la même manière c'est-à-dire en
argumentant mon point de vue et il nous
élevait en disant
que il nous éduquait pour nous rendre
capable de se passer de lui j'aimais
beaucoup cette formule il disait aussi
que l'obéissance sans sans critique et
la vertu des imbéciles je veux dire que
inconsciemment il nous préparait tout à
fait à
résister quand vous êtes engagé dans la
résistance de qui vous receviez vos vos
ordres de qui vous saviez ce qu'il
fallait faire alors au début on a fait
une résistance si j'ose dire très simple
c'est-à-dire que je recevais mes ordres
de mon frère et de son ami Gilbert Dru
qui eux étaient avec des gens plus
important et c'est eux qui me m'ont
m'ont nommé employé m'ont nommé agent de
liaison si vous voulez m'ont employé
comme agent de liaison et qui m'ont dit
où je devais aller porter les tractes et
les journaux clandestins que je ne
distribuais pas j'ai déposé dans un
endroit qu'on appelait une boîte aux
lettres qui était en réalité un magasin
et là des diffuseurs venaient les
chercher pour les distribuer et c'est
eux
euh qui qui si vous voulez m' m'ont
entraîné là-dedans mais après j'ai fait
connaissance euh d'un responsable et euh
c'est j'ai fait suis rentrée dans
l'organisation des forces unies de la
jeunesse les fuges on appelait ça qui
est devenu après les jeunes des
mouvements Unis de résistance sous
l'impulsion de Jean Moulin qui
souhaitait que nous fassions alliance à
avec les Jeunesses communistes et avec
les jeunes chrétiens combattants dirigés
par Gilbert Dru ce qu'on a fait de façon
à être plus efficace ça a été le gros
souci de Chan moulin hein et après donc
je recevais mes
ordres d'un garçon qui lui-même les
recevait d'autres si vous voulez
l'organisation de la la résistance elle
était très pyramidale en haut il y avait
Jean Moulin il y avait mettons 20 30
personnes qui le connaissaient chacune
de ces 30 personnes en connaissait
d'autres et ça se transmettait comme ça
si vous voulez c'est pour ça que quand
l'un d'entre nous était arrêté c'était
parfois difficile de remonter la
filière c'est surtout en 41 42 avant
l'arrivée des Allemands en zone libre
que nous avons fait des
manifestation on l'a trouvé belle cette
femme qui incarnait la République parce
que pour nous à l'époque la République
ça voulait dire un tas de choses ça
voulait dire
que que c'était qu'on éétait pas pour
Pétin
ça voulait dire liberté égalité
fraternité qui était
menacé
donc c'était é mouvant pour nous de
venir la saluer alors on s'installait là
tous ensemble on chantait la
Marseillaise et puis on regardait si la
police arrivait parce qu'elle pouvit
arriver évidemment de n'importe où et
généralement ils arrivaient par le même
chemin c'estàd par le même chemin que
nous ils étai c'était des policiers à
bicyclette et ils posaient leur vélos
contre des arbres il y avait plus
d'arbres ce sol n'existait pas il y
avait des arbres jusque là il posaient
donc leur vélo contre un arbre et puis
ils enlevaient leur CAP et à ce
moment-là nous on commençait à se mettre
en garde parce que les capes avait des
ourlets qui étaient garnis de pastilles
de plomb si bien que quand il nous
tapait dessus avec ça faisait très mal
donc quand il commençait à enlever les
capes il avent posé le vélo ils avaient
enlevé la CAP nous on était prêt on
était dans les starting blocks on était
prêt à partir
et on avait ordre de s'égailler dans
tous les sens pour qu'ils hésitent après
lequel qu'il sachent pas tout de suite
après lequel ils allaient courir alors
ça nous donnait une demi-seonde une
seconde d'avance et après on courait
faut dire qu'à l'époque les policiers
n'avaient pas d'entraînement sportif et
c'était pas des jeunes gens les
policiers c'étaaient plutôt des hommes
de 40 50 ans donc il nous
rattrapait enfin très très rarement une
fois de camarades de mon frère ont été
attrapés ils ont passé la nuit au poste
et puis on les a relâché le lendemain
matin donc on prenait pas de grand
risque et on était très content de
montrer au lyonnais que qu'on était pas
d'accord avec Pétin que on était prêt à
à se battre il faut dire que j'ai mesuré
après queon avait la vie vraiment plus
facile en zone libre en zone occupée
quand on a été occupé à partir de
novembre 42 je me suis rendu compte que
on avait bénéficié auparavant d'une
liberté de manœuvre qui n'ont jamais eu
en zone occupée mais on en a bien
profité est-ce que vous vous souvenez
des premiers allemands rencontrés dans
les rues en novembre
1942 quel sentiment avez-vous ressenti
ah oui je m'en souviens bien parce que
je les ai pas rencontré je suis allée
les voir on nous avait dit partez vite
on ne sait pas dans quel état d'esprit
sont les Allemands qui viennent
d'arriver et nous on s'est enfin moi je
me suis dit avec une camarade euh je
voudrais bien quand même les voir parce
qu'on se battait contre des gens qu'on
avait pasevu depuis 40 qu'on avait à
peine vu en
40 et finalement on se battait contre
contre le nazisme un mot enisme
c'est-à-dire une théorie on se battait
contre on se battait pour un idéal
contre quelque chose de pas tellement
clair et là les voilà qui arrivaiit donc
on s'est précipité vers la place
Bellecour et on a fini par les voir
j'avais rencontré entre-temps un de mes
frères avec un de ses camarades ça
m'avait donné du courage et vraiment là
ça a été un choc un choc que que
j'imaginais pas parce que j'ai vu toutes
ces voitures c'est bien rangé sur la
place bellcour euh ces garçons qui étai
bien droit beau bien habillé qui avait
un air
ouais de beau combattant et tout d'un
coup j'ai pris conscience qu'on se
battait contre quelque chose de bien
plus fort que nous si vous voulez c'est
devenu pour moi concret hein alors que
c'était avant une image une
idée ah mais voilà dans ce petit jardin
qui me rappelle tant de souvenir
émouvant et heureux parce que jamais
personne je crois ne s'y est fait
arrêter
voilà et
ici c'est
ban accueilleer nos
rendez-vous assez
fréquemment pourquoi est-ce que ce lieu
nous nous convenait c'est
essentiellement que c'était un
lieu tranquille paisible on y voyait pas
de police on y voyait pas de d'allemand
et on se donnait rendez-vous là avec il
y avait beaucoup d'étudiants qui
venaient apprendre des cours lire des
des textes faire des choses et on
retrouvait toujours plus ou moins des
camarades entre guillemets innocents si
vous voulez souvent on venait à deux
garçons et filles en particulier un de
mes camarades qui était préparé
l'agrégation de lettres et qui
s'appelait
jean-bernardi m'a souvent accompagné ici
alors on
s'assayyait un peu l'un contre l'autre
quelquefis il me passait le bras autour
de mes épaules ou nous nous essayons
d'avoir l'air amoureux modestement mais
enfin il fallait quand même un peu
donner le change et alors là on pouvait
se raconter tout ce qu'on voulait et
puis il y en avait un qui arrivait qui
était celui avec qui on avait
rendez-vous et à ce moment-là bon on
accueillait d'une
manière tout à fait correcte mais sans
plus et puis on se mettait à parler on
se disait ce qu'on avait à se
dire évidemment il y a eu d'autres lieu
de rendez-vous plus ou moins heureux il
y avait les cafés il y avait les
églises les églises ça me plaisait bien
aussi parce que je pense que jamais
enfin pour autant que je sache la
guestapo n'a pu imaginer que en faisant
sa prière à côté de quelqu'un on pouvait
lui raconter lui donner rendez-vous lui
raconter des choses
antinazie euh où se passer des documents
et à ma
connaissance en tout cas en ce qui me
concerne moi je n'ai jamais été inquiété
et même je dirais que ça nous amusait
c'était une espèce de détournement qui
qui nous faisait rire parce que vous
savez ça pas toujours été tragique la
résistance on a eu des bons moments des
moments d'abord des moments d'amitié
extraordinaires l'amitié elle avait un
goût et une force particulière parce
qu'on savait jamais si on se reverrait
le lendemain surtout à partir de 43 donc
notre amitié
avait il y avait une espèce pas
d'angoisse mais quand même un petit peu
dans notre amitié il y avait le le
sentiment du du pas durable le sentiment
du du fragile de l'aléatoire et et ça ça
ça donne des sentiments
particuliers les rendez-vous c'était
toujours un moment agréable avec
l'angoisse en arrivant cependant de pas
trouver l'autre ça je m'en souviens très
bien
euh on a on avait rendez-vous et puis
alors il fallait pas arriver trop en
avance bien sûr et puis si au bout de 5
10 minutes l'autre était pas là on
commençait à être inquiet et souvent
même on allait déambuler en attendant
qu'il arrive en se disant s'il a été
arrêté et que par hasard il est
parlé attention le rendez-vous devient
un piège quand un de nos camarades
proches était arrêté et qu'on était
prévenu on avait hordre de ramasser les
papiers de les cacher de de faire comme
si rien n'était comme si de rien n'était
euh
et puis parce qu'on savait que notre
camarade nos camarades avaient le droit
dans ça se disait euh de pas tenir le
coup au bout de 48
he alors c'était le le risque si on
traînait de de se faire
prendre en octobre 40 quand une femme
était sur le trottoir et que il y avait
pas la place de passer c'était le soldat
allemand qui descendait dans la
quand ils sont venus en 42 c'était ils
nous faisait descendre dans la rue hein
la mentalité avait changé au début ils
espéraent qu'on allait les accepter que
ça serait la collaboration en 42 j'
avais compris qu'on les accepterait pas
donc à ce moment-là notre vie a changé
et il fallait être dans le plus grand
secret ne pas se faire remarquer donc
plus de manifestation euh et les
résistants ceux qui n'avaiit pas encore
pris un nom de guerre un pseudonyme en N
pris un à ce moment-là et nous avions de
ne pas nous réunir les uns chez les
autres et même quand il y en avait de
nouveau que nous ne connaissions pas il
fallait pas connaître ni leur vrai nom
ni leur adresse est-ce que vous devinez
pourquoi il fallait rester dans cette
ignorance si vous faisiez arrêter ou
torturer vous pouviez le dire voilà je
peux pas dire mieux c'est bien euh donc
on avait peur mais même dans ma propre
famille quand on avait besoin de savoir
ce que faisait l'autre mon frère ou mon
père on se le disait mais quand c'était
pas une nécessité on se le disait pas
parce que nous avions très peur l'un ou
l'autre de nous faire arrêter et de
parler de notre frère de notre père sous
la torture hein euh donc secret pour la
sécurité moi j'aimerais savoir si vous
avez déjà eu envie d'abandonner en fait
ah que vous é ça c'est une bonne
question et bien je vais peut-être
t'étonner mais parmi mes camarades j'en
connais aucun qui a abandonné de sa
propre volonté j'en connais euh bon un
Monné parce qu'ils étaient recherchés
mais là on leur demandait de se mettre
au vert comme on disait à l'époque mais
on avait pas envie d'abandonner pour une
bonne raison c'est que
euh d'abord à partir de de 43 à partir
de la guerre avec la Russie on a
commencé à voir se dessiner la victoire
l'entrée des Allemands des Américains
dans la guerre tout ça nous a donné un
peu d'espoir et puis surtout moi et et
je pense beaucoup d'autres on a vécu la
résistance comme une passion alors ça
vous paraît peut-être bizarre mais une
passion c'est quand plus rien ne compte
que l'objet de cette passion et bien
nous nous étions amoureux de la liberté
si j'ose ainsi m'exprimer et je crois
vraiment que nous avons vécu la
résistance comme une passion j'ose le
dire parce que c'est vrai hein plus rien
d'autre ne comptait et du coup on avait
même moins
peur
il était si beau ce pond des
Guillotière avant que les Allemands ne
le détruisent en quittant Lyon en
septembre
44 il était très ancien il avait été
long à
construire et maintenant c'est un pont
banal mais pour pour moi ça reste un
pont intéressant parce que j'y ai un
souvenir à la fois heureux et et assez
terrible j'étais sur le pont là et je
marchais comme ça quand tout d'un coup
j'ai vu arriver au bout du pont une
camionnette de soldat
allemand ils sont mis en rang et ils ont
bouché le la sortie du pont alors
aussitôt je me suis retourné pour voir
si je pouvais pas repartir de l'autre
côté et puis non c'était pareil les deux
camionnettes étaient arrivé en même
temps donc nous étions pris sur le pont
comme dans un piège comme des rats et
nous étions assez nombreux et j'avais
une serviette comme on en avait à
l'époque à
double double poche donc assez grande
assez lourde dans laquelle j'avais des
papiers
compromettants comme par exemple des
tracs ou des journaux clandestins
et je ramenais mon petit frère de classe
et tout d'un coup j'ai eu une idée qui
s'est avéré bonne mais un peu dangereuse
alors je lui dit écoute Bernard on va
échanger nos cartes armé tout doucement
sans le poser par terre
et à ce moment-là tu sortiras alors tu
sortiras avec mon cartable tu passeras
entre l'homme de la Gestapo et le
soldat et tu feras un sourire au soldat
essaye de passer en même temps que
quelqu'un d'autre tu feras un sourire au
soldat et Bernard qui savait que il se
passait des choses bizarres à la
maison il a pas hésité et nous avons
échangé nos cartables en douceur et puis
il est parti devant et je lui avais dit
marche d'un pas tranquille et quand tu
auras dépassé le le barrage ne te mets
surtout pas à courir rentre
tranquillement à la maison je te
rattraperai et si tu as un ennui j'irai
de sortir de là
et puis je l'ai
regardé avec évidemment beaucoup de
d'inquiétude d'angoisse même et puis
j'ai vu qu'il passait il a fait un
sourire au soldat et le soldat lui a
caressé la tête et ouf j'ai repris ma
respiration et je me suis dit ça y est
le plus dur est passé moi je suis passée
ensuite avec son petit cartable le je
suis passée près de l'homme de la
guestapo et il m'a fait m'a regardé mes
papiers qui étaient encore mes vrais
papiers donc pas de problème il m'a fait
ouvrir mon cartable il a vu un petit
livre un petit cahier il m'a dit ça va
je suis passé et puis j'ai rattrapé mon
frère en marchant un peu plus vite que
lui il était très fier de ce qu'il avait
fait parce qu'il avait eu conscience que
il m'avait tiré d'affaire et je lui ai
dit coute disien un maman parce que ça
va lui faire peur puis je pensais que
c'était pas très simple et quand on est
arrivé à la maison dès qu'il a vu sa
mère notre mère il s'est précipité dans
ses bras et il lui a dit maman tu sais
pas ce qu'on vient de faire alors il a
raconté ma mère d'un air choquée s'est
tourné vers moi mais mais Denise comment
as-tu pu faire ça je dit écoute maman si
j'avais pas fait je serais pas revenue
elle m'a dit ah oui c'est vrai et j'ai
réalisé quelques années après sa mort
que nous n'en avions jamais reparlé je
dois dire que quand j'y repense
maintenant euh je me dis que j'ai
peut-être été inconsciente mais à ma
décharge je dirais que nous ne savions
pas à l'époque ce que les nazis
pouvaient faire euh aux petits enfants
hein donc j'ai pensé qu'au pire ils
allaient arrêter mon frère et que j'irai
le dédoaner et que je dirais c'est à moi
laissez-le partir et je pensais que les
choses se passeraient bien euh
aujourd'hui j'en suis moins sûr mais bon
j'ai de la chance ça s'est bien passé
donc je conclus que nous avons bien fait
non VO bonjour bonjour vous allez bien
oui merci affè s'il vous plaîton bonjour
vous
posez
bonjour
[Musique]
posé des
numér vous aurez un moment tout à
l'heure pour poser des questions
importantes mais si vous avez des des
questions rapides à me poser vous vous
gnez n'est
pas alors ah il y a la milice avant le
STO où est-ce qu'il est le STO plus loin
ah voilà alors puisqu'on a la milice
avant je vais vous parler de la milice
euh ça c'est une lettre grecque qui
s'appelle le GAM c'était l'insigne des
miliciens qu'est-ce que c'était que les
miliciens c'était des gens comme vous et
moi généralement des jeunes
gens généralement des jeunes gens euh
qui avaient décidé de suivre la gastapo
alors ils avaient un bel uniforme euh
ils avaient un bel uniforme noir ils
avaient un pistolet sur la hanche et il
nous faisait très peur pourquoi il nous
faisait plus peur que la guestapo est-ce
que vous pourriez deviner ou comprendre
pourquoi vas-y dis ce que tu penses
parce qu'il tuis oui il mais la guestapo
aussi ouais mais étaient il étaient
d'une violence égale à la guestapo mais
ils étaient français c'est ce que
j'allais et c'est ce que j'allais dire
ils étaient français a fait qu'ils
étaient français ben voilà ils
trahissent c'est alors d'abord c'était
des traîtres pour nous donc on les
haïissait plus que la guestapo et puis
par sur le marché ils étaient de notre
culture ils parlaient notre langue ils
nous connaissaient dans le quartier où
j'habitais il y avait deux familles qui
avait une fille qui était allée en
classe avec moi en école primaire et qui
avait un fils qui était milicien donc
dans mon quartier je croisais ces deux
gars pistolet sur la hanche il voyait
rentrait chez nous quand on parlait
entre nous il comprenait ce qu'il disait
alors que les hommes de la Gestapo
souvent ne comprenaient pas moi je me
suis tiré d'affaire sur le pont de la
Guillotière
euh où j'avais un cartable une serviette
avec des papiers dangereux je me suis
tiré d'affire parce que c'est un homme
de la guestapo qui a contrôlé euh nos
nos cartables ça aurait été un milicien
il aurait tout de suite compris que
c'était pas un cartable d'une fille de
mon âge hein mais là c'était un homme de
la gastapo il n'a pas compris compris
donc les miliciens nous faisaient plus
peur et on les haïsait encore plus que
les hommes de la
guestapo alors vous allez vous voyez là
le nom de Philippe enriot figurez-vous
que moi ça me dit quelque chose parce
que Philippe hriot était un homme très
cultivé qui avait
un une capacité de parler absolument
remarquable il était intelligent
convaincant
euh il était très persuasif et il
parlait à Radio Paris alors vous verrez
vous entendrez les messages de la BBC à
un moment on entend radio Paris M radio
Paris M radio Paris est allemand ça veut
dire n'écoutez pas radio Paris parce que
Radio Paris est sous une censure
allemande tellement forte qu'en réalité
il fait la propagande allemande et celui
qui faisait la propagande allemande
c'était Philippe hriot peu à peu les
Français se sont dit Philippe hriot il
faut s'en débarrasser et il y a eu des
projets dans plusieurs ville-de- France
de se débarrasser de Philippe hriot moi
j'étais pas grande je paraissais pas mon
âge et des camarades qui faisait partie
d'un groupe franc
euh dont un des responsables d'ailleurs
celui qui m'a appris à tirer au revolver
a été fusillé à la
Ducher ses camarades se sont dit bien
Philippe enriot on va le faire
disparaître quand il viendra à Lyon il
devait venir à Lyon et il devait parler
sur les marches de de la Grande Poste et
euh on m'a donc désigné pour pour la
battre et moi à l'époque quand j'y
repense aujourd'hui je je sais plus quoi
penser parce que à l'époque se
débarrasser de Philippe enriot pour moi
c'était un devoir or c'était tu es un
homme mais cet homme était pour moi un
malfaisant c'est à cause de lui que des
gens se faisaient arrêter déporter
fusiller et
cetera donc il fallait le faire taire et
quel autre moyen de le faire taire que
de le
supprimer donc à l'époque ce qui me
paraît aujourd'hui terrible c'est-à-dire
prendre la vie d'un homme ça me
paraissait justice c'est pour ça que la
guerre est terrible parce que la guerre
elle vous fait vivre dans la violence
intérieure et dans la violence
extérieure hein euh et cette violence
intérieure je l'avais en moi comme la
plupart des résistants même si elle
transparaissait pas dans des actes de
violence de violence je veux dire nos
sentimement était violent
notre notre désir de résister c'était
devenu passionnel hein
donc on m'a préparé à ça ça devait être
fait avec des gens qui me protégeaient
et cetera et puis une semaine avant
Philippe enriot a été tué à Paris par
des résistants et j'ai échappé à cette
affaire qui me
paraissait à l'époque bien organisé mais
dont je pense aujourd'hui que si ça
avait marché je serais pas là pour vous
le
raconter
un arbre qui est pas tout jeune il a dû
me voir passer
celui-là
grand voilà et ben c'était par là j'en
suis sûr on peut
entrer c'est quand même une belle
salle voilà un endroit où j'ai passé des
moments euh heureux même s'ils étaient
stressant heureux et plein de
d'enthousiasme et et de vie il y avait
beaucoup de de cours qui se passait là
non c'était la
bibliothèque il y avait des tables et
puis on était et là il distribuaiit les
livres ils allait les chercher ah voilà
la fraise moi j'ai jamais dû lever le
nez je m'en souviens pas
j'étais tellement studieuse je devais
pas lever la fig lever les
yeux ah oui alors je m'en souviens pas
du tout il est vrai que quand on est là
on la voit peut-être
pas
si alors que ça c'est marrant parle tout
à fait donc là c'était ds le début là
vous êtes rentré donc quelle époque donc
en novembre 43 oui puisque la fac
rentrait seulement en novembre euh et là
très vite je me suis trouvée en pays
amis à cause des camarades de de mon
frère aîné
et et donc je me suis trouvé chez moi
enfin vraiment c'est pour ça que j'en
garde un
souvenir heureux et ému en même
temps parce que c'est un endroit où
vraiment j'ai j'ai vécu à
plein et j'attendais ça depuis la classe
de de 6e je crois très vite j'ai été
recruté euh pour travailler dans les
faux papiers parce que j'avais suivi des
codes calligraphie pendant 3 ans ma mère
voulait que j'apprenne le piano
évidemment j'ai eu envie de faire autre
chose et nous avons conclu un accord sur
les codes calligraphie et j'ai beaucoup
aimé ça j'en ai refait d'ailleurs depuis
et donc j'avais une écriture j'écrivais
vite et bien euh et puis je pouvais
surtout imiter des signatures puisque la
calligraphie c'est un art qui consiste à
imiter des lettres que nous voyons et
qui sont un peu compliqués en panaché
parfois euh donc vraiment imiter les
signatur ne ne me coûtait aucune peine
et j'ai encore des papiers à la maison
où j'avais marqué ce qu'il fallait faire
et cetera et ça c'est un souvenir
important ceux qui demandaient des
papiers n'étaient jamais en contact avec
ceux qui les faisaient hein comme ça moi
je ne savais absolument pas pour qui je
faisais tel ou tel pied on celle qui
s'en occupait venait en nous
disant voilà il faut si possible on
mettait les mêmes initiales euh s'il
avait une visage un peu âgé on le
faisait naître en en 19 en 18 à ce
moment-là il fallait des papiers
militaires aussi et s'il avait un visage
assez jeune on le faisait nîre en
24 23 24 en 23 ou 24 oui et il y avait
toujours besoin aussi des papierers
d'alimentation bien sûr sans lesquels on
serait mort de faim les cartes
d'alimentation
euh voilà donc moi j'ai jamais vu les
gens pour qui j'ai pu faire des cartes
et puis il y avait tout un travail aussi
pour les
rendre conforme à ce que pouvaient
trouver ceux qui demandaient les papiers
c'est-à-dire les cartes à l'époque
étaient en carton et il fallait qu'elles
ait l'air d'avoir traîné dans les poches
une carte
Neuve provoqua immédiatement un contrôle
donc il fallait que enfin on les
frottait avec du papier journal on
marchait dessus je veux dire on leur
donnait un
air un peu usé alors on était soutenu
par un appariteur qui s'appelait
monsieur carer et je voit encore sa sa
silhouette que nous appelions
familièrement
carotte et qui était tout à fait
favorable à à ce que nous faisions et il
veillit bien à regard qui rentrait à la
fac et si c'était une tête inconnue
prévenait que l'ennemi était dans la
place même si ça n'était pas un
ennemi donc je garde aussi beaucoup de
reconnaissance à ce monsieur que je n'ai
jamais
revu parce que à sa façon il nous a
aidé je montrer quelque chose que vous
verrez pas
souvent ça s'appelle la cuisine de notre
temps c'est un titre humoristique vous
vous en doutez ça s'appelle en haut les
recettes de tante Lucy et dessous publié
avec l'approbation du secrétariat d'État
à la santé publique hein donc c'est tout
à fait innocent c'est fait avec le
papier de l'époque donc vous voyez la
qualité et derrière il y a une de ces
phrases je les qualifierai pas parce que
j'aurais envie de dire un vilain mot il
y a une de ces phrases que le maréchal
nous dit disait et qu'il écrivait
partout la femme française en dépit de
nos cruelles épreuves demeure une
excellente cuisinière voilà alors si
vous ouvrez ça qu'est-ce que vous
trouvez là vous trouvez des quantités
d'indications parce qu'on nous avait
fourni on s'est pas mis à faire des faux
papiers comme ça sans rien hein on nous
avait fourni moi j'ai été engagé le truc
était déjà en route j'étaé engagé à
cause de pour imiter les signatures
surtout euh mais ils avaient des tampons
euh on savait où il fallait les faire
naître on en faisait naître en Afrique
du Nord on en venait dans des villes
bombardées et cetera mais là on a eu des
des éléments très très intéressants pour
les certificats de travail pour les
papier militair et puis pour les dates
des jours fériers car une carte s'il y
avait un contrôle un peu poussé sin nous
on avait tamponné la carte on le mettait
né en 1919 et un dimanche hein et bien
on le faisait arrêter aussitôt parce que
la guestap elle avait prévu ça et là on
avait les dates des jours fériers donc
on risquait pas de faire une erreur
voilà alors cherchons le
confessionnal
ah ah ah est-ce que ça pourrait ça y
est voà j'y
suis
et les confessionnaux à l'époque avaient
souvent un petit rideau devant ce qui
faisait que on pouvait se cacher à
l'intérieur
ah nous sommes
arrivés le soir l'église était encore
ouverte et qu' y avait pas grand monde
ah et puis j'ai proposé à Madame rivière
de se camoufler dans ce confessionnal il
était recherché et surtout il était
recherché euh avec sa photo c'est-à-dire
que la guestapo ayant sa photo il était
vraiment en grand danger et il voulait
partir dans le maquis dans les maquis de
lin et il fallait quand même qu'il passe
la nuit avant de
partir donc je lui ai proposé un
confessionnal et il s'est caché là pour
la nuit et le matin et bien après
l'ouverture de par le sacristin
l'ouverture des portes par le
sacristin il est parti
alors je veux pas dire que je lui ai
sauvé la vie ça serait très prétentieux
mais on a mis tous les atouts du bon
côté pour que ils s'en sorte je me
rappelle plus exactement la date mais
c'était en 44 à une époque où la
guestapo était
terrible à une époque où plusieurs de
nos
amis se sont fait arrêter et puis à
l'époque se faire arrêter quand on était
accusé de rés c'était pour les garçons
se faire fusiller généralement et pour
les filles se faire déporter c'était ça
été une époque très très très
dure mais c'est amusant parce que je
retrouve quand même un semblant de
souvenir
et ce qu'il faut dire c'est ça peut
paraître curieux mais on avait des
moments de de grande joie quand on jouit
quand on jouait un tour au aux autorités
d'occupation c'est-à-dire que quand on
avait réussi bon quelque chose comme ça
on était heureux malgré le le drame que
que vivaient beaucoup de gens à l'époque
malgré le le tragique de la situation on
avait des moments
de presque de gêé je dirais parce que
arrivver à à se moquer
de la guestapo c'était un grand grand
plaisir
début juin
44 j'ai su qu'il fallait que j'étais
recherché par le responsable de mon
groupe
et donc il fallait immédiatement que je
parte alors le soir j'en ai parlé à mon
père et mon
père m'a dit je vais caché à la campagne
et moi j'ai pas voulu ça me semblait
lâche et puis je sentais que le vent
tournait que on allait avoir la victoire
je voulais pas rater ça donc j'ai
protesté
et mon père a insisté et puis je lui a
dit écoute papa si tu voulait pas qu'on
y aille il fallait pas nous élever comme
ça alors il a souri et puis il m'a donné
de l'argent et il m'a donné l'adresse de
d'un de ses amis qui nous servirait de
de liaison parce que il fallait ni
écrire ni téléphoner ni se montrait bien
entendu j'allais plus à la fac et cetera
j'étais vraiment dans la clandestinité
et ça a été une
expérience difficile parce que j'ai
pensé à tous ceux qui avaient vécu
quelques années comme ça dans sous une
fausse identité sans savoir parfois où
il coucherait le
soir après la vie vibrante exaltante
dangereuse et active que j'avais mené
voilà que je me retrouve devant des
dissertations de 4h et des thèmes latins
euh ça a été très très très dur j'ai eu
la chance de tomber malade et j'ai été
envoyé dans une maison de repos pour
étudiants résistants à comblou près de
près de
mesgèves alors là bon nous avons été
très heureux nous avions la visite de
gens importants de Paris parce que
c'était il y ait beaucoup d'étudiants
des grandes écoles de Paris et nous
avons passé 3 mois bien nourri par la
Croix-Rouge américaine et la Croix-Rouge
suédoise puis tout d'un coup on nous a
dit il y a deux résistantes qui vont AR
de pardon de déportter résist qui vont
arriver et on savait à quelle heure
elles arrivaient on s'est on a préparé
une fête on s'est mis sur de rangs pour
les accueillir et on a vu quand le taxi
s'est arrêté on a vu descendre de deux
femmes de jeunes femmes qui traînaient
les pieds qui étaiit horriblement maigre
mal fagoté euh et qui nous ont même pas
regardé pas de regard bien sûr ils nous
ont encore moins parler évidemment on
les a pas applaudi on les a regardé
passer et on s'est dit on nous a envoyé
des grandes malades et puis elles sont
montées dans leur chambrre le directeur
est allé leur parler puis il nous a
réuni avant le repas de midi et il nous
a dit euh j'ai une terrible nouvelle à
vous annoncer al là je vous rapporte les
mots exacts parce qu'ils me sont restés
vraiment dans la mémoire j'ai une
terrible nouvelle à vous annoncer la
plupart des déportés ne rentreront pas
alors ça a été vraiment euh un désespoir
général on était tous résistants donc on
avait tous des camarades en déportation
et pire encore il y en avait beaucoup
comme la résistance a souvent été une
histoire de famille en avait beaucoup
qui avaient de la famille en
déportation la plupart se sont mis à
pleurer il y en a qui se sont évanouis
ça été vraiment un spectacle de de
désolation ça c'est pour vous prouver
que vraiment nous ne savions pas ce qui
se passait dans les camps de
concentration nous nous doutions bien
que il recevait des coups de bâton qui
travaillaient beaucoup qu'ils avaient
froid qu'ils avaient faim plus que nous
et cetera mais l'horreur la
déshumanisation les humiliations
permanente franchement c'était
impensable pour nous vous vous savez que
ça existait euh pour nous quand je dis
impensable ça veut dire impossible à
penser on pensait pas que des hommes
pouvaient faire ça à d'autres hommes
hein donc leur expérience était
incommunicable puisque pour nous elle
était impensable pour eux elle devenait
incommunicable moi j'en ai revu après
des résistants et il m'a fallu presque
je dirais des mois pour ne pas dire des
années pour commencer à imaginer ce
qu'ils avaient pu vivre hein au début on
a même cru parfois qu'ils exagéraient
pour se faire plaindre hein parce que on
pouvait pas y croire et la plupart des
déportés n'ont pas pu parler parce
qu'ils sentaiit très bien qu'on éétait
pas capable de les écouter on voulait
être gentil mais c'était pas de ça
qu'ils avaient besoin on était gentil
c'est tout mais eux ils étaient ils
avaient besoin de se reconstruire
complètement et nous on était incapable
de les aider on était c'est comme si on
était sur une autre rive si vous
voulezar
je Denis hen la France
mou mort pour la France men Robert mort
pour la France debz Henri André mort
pour la France Charin Lucien mort pour
la France chambau PAUL MARIUS mort pour
la
[Musique]
France
qui brisons les barreaux des prisons
pour nos
[Musique]
frères not trou c'est la fin qui nous
pousse la
misère
il y a des pays où les gens au creux du
lit font des
rêves ici nous voit-tu nous on marche
nous on tue nous on
crève ami si tu tombes un ami sort de
l'ombre à ta
place
routes qu'est-ce que vous retenez de
cette expérience alors ah ça c'est une
bonne question alors moi jeenseten la
première chose qui me vient à l'esprit
et ça c'est vraiment très très fort en
moi euh c'est que
euh il faut jamais eu il y a quelqu'un
hein on peut se battre on peut gronder
quand on est prof on peut punir on en a
même le devoir hein parfois mais jamais
humilier parce que humilier
quelqu'un c'est le mettre à terre c'est
l'empêcher de de réagir correctement si
vous voulez aider quelqu'un faut pas
l'humilier et l'humiliation ça a été une
arme terrible des nazis un SS qui a dit
un jour à un juif tu n'es pas un homme
tu n'es même pas un chien tu n'es qu'un
juif hein
euh c'est et dans les camp de con
conentration ils ont été humiliés et
nous aussi ils nous humiliait quand on
ils étaient ici l'humiliation était
vraiment pour eux une arme très très
forte la déshumanisation que qu'ils ont
connu dans les camps c'était une arme et
puis je je pense que faut pas se laisser
marcher sur les pieds hein et que je
regrette pas enfin c'est une image un
peu vulgaire marcher sur les pieds mais
je veux dire que c'est luci aurac qui a
dit que résister se conjugue toujours au
présent c'est un verbe qui se toujours
au présent vous aurez l'occasion il y a
pas besoin qu'il y ait la guerre avec
les nazis hein pour résister il y a
d'abord le fait de pas accepter qu'on
dise n'importe quoi devant vous le fait
de ne pas quand vous voyez humilier
quelqu'un de le défendre c'est
Montesquieu qui a dit une injustice
faite à un seul est une menace faite à
tous vous allez vous rappeler répète-moi
ça c'est une injustice faite à un seul
est une menace faite à tous parfait
alors vous vous en
souviendrez vous vous en souviendrez
parce que
parce que c'est facile de laisser
humilier les autres devant soi hein
alors si on est du bon côté ben tendons
la main à ceux qui sont du mauvais côté
[Musique]
hein